[موسيقى]
لاال انا بسام
بركات احنا بنيجي على هذه المرشحه عشان
نترفع لانه هذه الحرب كانت قاسيه وكانت
حرب قويه وكانت حرب مشش مكان كانت صعبه
صعبه واحنا تهجرنا على رفح من غزه لخن
يونس للدير للوسط ورفح وانجلينا للي بسو
واللي بسوا
وبس اسمي حلا محمد بركات بنيجي على
المرجحه عشان نترفع نغير عن الجو اللي ننا
فيه وكل يوم ضرب وصواريخ وبنخاف والاطفال
بيجوا مرتعب بييجوا على المرجح عشان يرحوا
على حالهم
انظلموا هالصغار
بهالحب حرام عليهم موتوا الاطفال
والنساء ايه نزحنا من غزه من الزيتون
نزحنا لغزه وكل اهلي واصحابي وابوي وكل
عيالنا بغزه واحنا نزحنا ل حالنا ونزح مع
امي وبس جينا لحالنا وحدين
وهينا متلقين على اللي بغزه وخايفين عليهم
ان شاء الله برجع لهم سالمين بعد هالحرب
يا رب ان شاء الله بتخلص على
[موسيقى]
سلام